(soft melodious music)
- [Narrator] Three and a quarter
miles east of Key Biscayne
near Miami, Florida, is an underwater
eternal resting place for ocean lovers.
The Neptune Memorial Reef is
an artificial, man-made reef
that houses the remains
of thousands of people.
After cremation, ashes
are mixed with cement
to form features that
become part of the reef.
The reef's design was inspired
by the underwater city Atlantis
and includes lion statues, columns,
benches, canopies and podiums.
It takes up half an acre and sits 40 feet
under the surface of the water.
The Neptune Memorial Reef
serves a dual purpose
as a home to many underwater creatures,
fulfilling its mission of
creating life after life.